[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well I want to thank Chris and Wayne I'm
thrilled to be here in Indiana with the
men and women of the NRA you are great
American patriots Chris Cox Wayne up
here Oliver North
I've been following Oliver for a long
time
great guy three extraordinary champions
for the Second Amendment and I'm a
champion for the Second Amendment and so
are you it's not going anywhere
it's under assault it's under assault
but not when we're here not even close
I also want to thank our tremendous vice
president and Indiana's native son Mike
Pence has done a fantastic job
I went grateful to be joined by a number
of terrific leaders from the Hoosier
State Governor Eric all come where's
Eric
you can't miss Eric he's so big thank
you Eric
senator Todd young terrific guy
Thank You Todd Senator Mike Braun what a
job he's doing
and representative Greg pence familiar
name
thank you good Jackie well our ski
Jackie thank you Jim Baird and Jim bags
great representatives thank you all very
much
tremendous help tremendous I also want
to recognize Secretary of the Interior
David Bernhardt what a job he's been
doing David thank you thank you
a great friend of mine Kentucky governor
Matt Bevin
thank you that and the House GOP whip a
man with more courage than most of us
here today he took some very very severe
shots you know that
you
and he is steve scalise lattaker thank
you Steve and most importantly I want to
thank all of you the proud card-carrying
members of the NRA every day you stand
up for our god-given rights without
exception without fail and without
apology together we are fighting for the
timeless values that have built and
sustained our nation and our nation is
greater today than it has ever been
stronger richer we're doing better than
ever before we are great Americans
you're doing a great job we believe in
the rule of law and we will always
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States
[Music]
there are some people that are running
right now I don't think they have that
number one on their list we believe that
children should be taught to love our
country honor our history and always
respect our great American flag and we
believe in the right to self-defense and
the right to protect your family your
community and your loved ones we believe
in the wisdom of our founders and we
believe in freedom and liberty and the
right to keep and bear arms
we know that faith and family not
government and bureaucracy are the
center of American life and above all
else we know this in America we don't
worship government we worship God
every day of my administration we are
taking power out of Washington DC and
returning it to the American people
where it belongs and you see it now
better than ever
with all of the resignations of bad
apples they're bad apples they tried for
a coup didn't work out so well
and I didn't need a gun for that one and
I
all was taking place at the highest
levels in Washington DC you've been
watching you've been seeing you've been
looking at things that you wouldn't have
believed possible in our country
corruption at the highest level a
disgrace spying surveillance trying for
an overthrow and we caught him we caught
him who would have thought in our
country but it's called
what we all together have done started
two and a half years ago on that great
November 8th I was a great day remember
that day a year and a half we have one
called November 3rd it's November 3rd
this time get ready to vote you better
you better get ready to vote but it's
all called draining the swamp and we are
doing it faster than anyone ever thought
possible very proud of
and around the world America is
respected again because we are finally
putting America first in a long time our
economy is now the hottest anywhere on
the planet Earth just this morning we
learned that the GDP smashed
expectations with the economy growing at
an annual rate of 3.2 percent in the
first quarter always the worst quarter
for whatever reason 3.2
and if we kept the same interest rates
and the same quantitative easing that
the previous administration had that
three point two would have been much
higher than that but they hadn't hit
these numbers in sixteen years we had a
tremendous increase in inventory
investment you know what that means
and listen to this a very big increase
in net exports is it at about time is
that that we've added almost six million
jobs since my election and if I would
have said that during the campaign all
of those people back there we call him
the fake dues
they wouldn't have believed they're fake
and sink
blue-collar jobs recently grew at the
fastest rate in more than three decades
nearly five million Americans have been
lifted off of food stamps
since our election wages are rising fast
and the lowest paid workers are making
the biggest percentage gains of all and
that's nice to hear it's about time
unemployment recently achieved its
lowest rate in 51 years and very shortly
it should be its lowest rate in the
history of our country African American
Hispanic American have reached the
lowest levels of unemployment in our
history America's future has never been
brighter and yet Democrats have never
been angrier
especially now that their collusion
delusion has been exposed to the world
as they complete and total fraud
it's been the greatest political hoax
ever in our country instead of working
with us to rebuild our infrastructure
lower drug prices which by the way this
year for the first time in 50 years drug
prices went down go down a lot lower and
instead of working with us to fix our
trade deals which I'm doing without and
continue creating millions and millions
of new jobs which we're doing at a level
that people have not seen before that
people don't even believe Democrats are
obsessed with hoaxes delusions and witch
hunts that's what they're obsessed with
that's what they want to do and we can
play the game just as well or better
than they do
far-left radicals in Congress want to
take away your voice your jobs your
rights and they especially want to take
away your guns you know that they want
to take away your guns you better get
out there and vote you better get out
there and vote it seems like it's a long
ways away it's not I was saying to
Melania a great first lady whose
birthday it is today happy birthday
Milani
I remember standing two and a half years
ago in the same hallway where Abraham
Lincoln and so many others have stood my
first night in the White House and I
said to milani I said this is incredible
and four years seemed so long away and
now here we are we're getting ready to
start up the campaign again start up the
campaign together I never want to do
anything with mega because mega country
and Magga make America great again has
been great but we've really made it
great we've made it great we brought it
back and we're thinking about slogan
Keep America great because you have
socialists and far-left Democrats that
want to destroy everything that we've
done your 401 KS are going through the
roof
use stock market since the election has
hit a record-high almost a hundred
different records I've broken record
high but everyone's like a genius now
they buy stock and they're all up
everybody's benefiting and jobs are
benefiting but it can all be taken away
when you start putting the wrong people
in office we've cut regulations more
than any president in the history of our
country
and that's in two years in two years we
did more to regulation think of that
than any president in the history of our
country it's one of the reasons their
jobs evolving one of the reasons the
economy is booming we gave you the
largest tax cut in the history of our
country the biggest ever
and we got Anwar approved and we got the
individual mandate the absolute worst
part of Obamacare eliminated now we're
going for the rest and we had it done
except for one vote you know what I'm
talking one vote in recent days leading
Democrats have proposed banning new guns
and confiscating existing guns from
law-abiding citizens what they don't
tell you is the bad guys aren't giving
up their guns and you're not going to be
giving up your guns either at the same
time
housed them recently voted against
notifying ice
these brave great talented brilliant
Patriots when an illegal alien attempts
to buy a gun which is a felony Democrats
also support sanctuary cities that
release thousands of dangerous criminal
aliens onto our streets in fact they
like the criminal aliens and alien so
much that when we're forced to release
them into our country because of the
horrible immigration laws that the
Democrats refused to give us the votes
we need some of their votes to change we
give them as many as they can handle and
they're not too happy about it folks
that do it they said who came up with
that idea they said only Trump could
come up with that idea
give them as many as they can handle
in other words Democrats want you to
soar law-abiding Americans while
allowing criminal aliens to operate with
impunity but that will never happen as
long as I'm your president not even
close
I promise to defend the Second Amendment
rights of every American and I always
will I'll never let you down never let
you down have it so far and I won't
because as the famous saying goes when
guns are outlawed only outlaws will have
guns very simple the Democrats are also
working hard to block the wall but we
are building the wall they're not happy
about it
and we will have over 400 miles of wall
built by the end of next year
building a lot of wall I want to thank
Border Patrol I want to thank our great
military I want to thank the Army Corps
of Engineers they've been incredible and
we are doing something that I could do
very quickly and we're doing it very
quickly but dealing with these people is
very very difficult if you haven't
noticed okay any politician would have
given up a long time ago so we'll have
over 400 miles of wall built by the end
of next year it's going up rapidly
rapidly
we're also renovating tremendous
stretches of wall we have wall that's in
bad shape but it's structurally sound
and rather than building new we renovate
it we make it as good as new
save a lot of money and we gain a lot of
territory so we have a lot of great
things going a lot of great things going
most importantly Democrats must change
our immigration laws right now right now
we can do it and I used to say 45
minutes we could do it in 15 minutes
it's very simple you know the programs
are horrible the asylum we're rough
tough ms-13 gang members come in you
don't want to meet with these people but
ice doesn't mind because ice is throwing
them out of our country by the thousands
and the Democrats want to eliminate us
can you believe that
boy oh boy but it's incredible what
they've done it's incredible
what we've done but they stand there
asylum and they read a statement I am
afraid for my life I am afraid to go
back to my country I want to be an
American
and you look and you see a toughness
that you don't see and you just see what
happens with the mayor of Tijuana and
others they say these people we try and
help them and they start hitting us they
start punching us we don't want them in
our country and they're not getting into
our country and when they have in the
past a lot of them have come in we're
throwing them the hell out they're out
but we can fix the problem so easy and
when we fix the problem the wall is one
thing and that will have an incredible
impact but they won't even be coming up
if we change our old broken ridiculous
weak immigration laws they won't even be
coming up they won't make the journey
the wall is still good to have we need
the wall but all of those people you see
coming up thousands and thousands of
people they won't be coming because
they're gonna say there's no way we can
get into the United States anymore
except by going through legal channels
and what we want is we want people we
need them for all of the great companies
that are coming in but people have to
come in to our country legally and
through merit through merit
one of the gravest threats through the
Second Amendment and to American freedom
itself are activist judges you see it
every day every day they almost always
file in a certain little jurisdiction I
won't tell you what it is but you all
know every time we get sued on the ban
which we ended up winning you know we
have the ban we lost in the Ninth
Circuit we shouldn't have we lost in the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals which we
shouldn't have and we wanted the United
States Supreme Court so we have the ban
travel ban but the reporters the other
day some reporters said Donald Trump who
lost the travel then I didn't listen
well what he meant I lost it in the
Ninth Circuit but he didn't say we won
at the United States Supreme Court
so everyone said oh that's too bad he
lost the trip no no we won the travel
ban in the United States Supreme Court
but they don't say that
so when we confront them they said no we
were referring to the lower courts I
said what about the upper court they
ruled it's done but we weren't talking
about the Supreme Court we're saying you
Lawson these are very very dishonest
people okay
[Applause]
nobody gets why they're opposed to
strong military they're opposed to all
of the things we've done including
making our nation wealthy including high
GDP s including all of the security and
all of the law enforcement all of the
things we're doing it's incredible
nobody understands that someday we're
gonna figure it out and I'll feel much
better about it but why are they opposed
to things that truly make our country
great why nobody gets in I don't get it
the level of dishonesty and corruption
in the media is unbelievable but we're
stuck with activist judges who seek to
rewrite our constitution to force their
own radical views onto our country that
is why my administration has led a
historic effort to confirm fair and
impartial and mostly conservative judges
who will interpret the Constitution as
written and I'm very proud to announce
that we will soon have 145 federal
judges confirm a record number including
two great Supreme Court judges
justice for such justice Cavanaugh -
fantastic
justices in fact next week we will
confirm our 100th federal judge nobody
knows what that means the percentage is
incredible nobody knows what that means
and in the end I expect to have the
second highest percentage of judges
confirmed in the history of the United
States more than any other president
except one I'll never beat this one
percentage of judges approved you know
the one is sake against George
Washington he gets a hundred percent now
he had a hundred percent
he named every one of them but you know
what we'll have more of them George
Washington but we're also defending free
speech on our college campuses last
month I signed an executive order
requiring public colleges and
universities to respect the First
Amendment rights of their students or
risk losing tens of billions of dollars
in federal funding you don't want to
hear another voice you don't get all of
this tremendous amount in some cases
ridiculous amounts of dollars
and we have shut down the previous
administrations massive abuse of power
known as operation choke point under
this ill-advised program government
bureaucrats discouraged banks from
making loans to gun retailers a backdoor
attack on private gun ownership that
will never be allowed to happen on my
watch that's step one
folks step one you know what step two
three and four is step four is you don't
have guns you don't have any way to
protect yourself today I'm proud to
announce another historic step to
protect your Second Amendment rights and
I didn't tell Chris and Wayne and Oliver
I didn't even tell him about it so
they're listening in this big room
someplace to they say I wonder what he's
going to do the good thing with me you'd
never know
that's why we're making trade deals
better so good for our country so in the
last administration President Obama
signed the UN arms trade treaty and it
is waning days at office he sent the
treaty to the Senate to begin the
ratification process this treaty
threatened your subjugate and you know
exactly what's going on here your rights
and your constitutional and
international rules and restrictions and
regulations under my administration we
will never surrender American
sovereignty to anyone we will never
allow foreign bureaucrats to trample on
your Second Amendment freedom and that
is why
my administration will never ratify the
UN arms trade treaty
I'm impressed I didn't think too many of
you would really know what it is you
know what it is a big a big factor but I
see a couple of very happy faces from
the NRA oh and I am officially
announcing today that the United States
will be revoking the effect of America's
signature from this badly misguided
treatment we're taking our signature
back the United Nations will soon
receive a formal notice that America is
rejecting this treaty
as part of this decision I will sign
right now in front of a lot of witnesses
a lot of witnesses a message asking the
Senate to discontinue the treaty
ratification Brussels and to return the
now rejected treaty right back to me in
the Oval Office where I will dispose of
it
by taking these actions we are
reaffirming that American liberty is
sacred and that American citizens live
by American laws not the laws of foreign
countries thank you
they all want the pen can you believe
these people should I give it to him
famous fan as we protect gun rights for
law-abiding citizens we are also getting
guns out of the hands of violent
criminals when I took office two years
ago one of my highest priorities was to
reduce violent crime in the two years
before my inauguration the murder rate
had increased by more than 20% and the
United States had experienced the
largest increase in violent crime in
over 25 years for this reason my
administration resurrected project safe
neighborhoods bringing together
prosecutors police sheriffs and citizens
groups to put the most dangerous
offenders behind bars we funded 200 new
violent crime prosecutors we charged a
record number of criminal offenders and
last year we prosecuted the most violent
criminals ever in our history and now
violent crime is way down murders in
America's largest cities dropped by six
percent between 2017 and 2018 but I do
have to ask you what the hell is going
on in Chicago what is going wrong we
could solve that problem we would have
been down even a lot more and it's not a
tough problem to solve you got to let
law enforcement do what they have to do
they'll solve the problem very quickly
very quickly
we don't think enough about the victims
they're too worried about the people
that caused the crime it's got to stop
that thought process is no good the
number of police officers shot and
killed in the line of duty last year
I'm so happy to report is down 21
percent compared to the year before and
that was the year before I took office
one of the reasons is that we are
supplying police with surplus military
equipment supplies and gears that the
previous administration refused to give
up this is surplus this is extra we
don't need it great equipment sitting in
warehouses all over the country billions
of dollars of equipment that the
military no longer needs or wants or
uses but the top of the line some of its
never been used brand-new from vehicles
to essentially supplies of all kind
including bulletproof vests and rather
than having it sit and draw dust
I had it distributed all over the
country to our police departments
[Applause]
and that's why you see these numbers
it's great thing you know a lot of being
president is common sense right don't
you think right
common sense have a good heart but it's
common sense in this administration we
will always stand with the heroes of law
enforcement they're heroes they're brave
they're great and they will tell you
they haven't felt so proud of themselves
for many years because they were
abandoned by Washington they were
abandoned by our politicians and not
just the Obama administration before
that they felt abandoned well they know
that I love them and we're going to
protect them just like they protect us
credible people great people we've also
taken critical steps to improve school
safety more than 30 states now allow
teachers that are highly trained highly
trained talented people to carry guns in
the classroom to protect themselves and
to protect their students who they love
who's better
I've been calling for that for the last
two years and I think we had a big
impact some legislations passed and they
don't have that few paragraphs and the
legislators actually go back to
governor's and say we're not passing it
unless you allow that to happen so we've
come a long way but who's better to
protect our students than the teachers
that love them through stopped school
violence grants we are helping local
schools and police departments to hire
more officers trained more teachers that
address early warning signs of mental
illness every day citizens across
America exercise their constitutional
right to defend themselves their
families and their communities that's a
constitutional right they want to take
it away from you they will take it away
you let these maniacs get into office
they will take that right away now we do
see what's going on let the Boston
bomber vote he should be voting right I
don't think so
let terrorists that are in prison vote I
don't think so
can you believe it but this is where
some of these people are coming from and
they're the most popular ones when
Bernie Sanders made certain statements
the other day I said well that's the end
of his campaign then what happened does
everybody agreed with him or most of
them we know that the only way to stop a
bad guy with a gun is a good guy with a
gun
I wanted to be a little bit more
original then to use the phrase that you
probably heard a thousand times but
what's a better phrase than that we
can't do better how simple is that
today I want to give a few of these